[Musique]
ma vie parce que c'est ce qui m'a permis
de grandir de m'épanouir de gagner des
trophées et d'être bien dans sa peau
c'est compliqué à répondre à cette
question mais je vois le football en
pleine progression
financièrement pour les joueurs mais
manque de spontanéité manque de
créativité
c'est bon de retrouver des joueurs comme
quand même bape et qui commence qui
recommencent à faire rêver
[Musique]
toute ma carrière je crois que j'ai
commencé à l'âge de 15 ans j'étais avec
des grands garçons
j'ai fini à 34 ans 20 ans de carrière
après il ya les championnats avec paris
avec marseille
les coupes d'europe avec paris toutes
ces victoires avec ses bandes de potes
c'est la solidarité qui avait à l'époque
dans toutes les équipes où j'ai joué